foreign
[Music]
today I'm excited to share more about
how Foundation models are now available
on vertex AI as part of our support for
bringing generative AI to you let's Dive
In
Foundation models are large AI models
that can be adapted to a wide range of
tasks and can generate high quality
output
so while AI models are not completely
new these Foundation models have several
important characteristics that represent
a change from the previous generation
Fai models Foundation models are
multitask rather than single tasks One
Foundation model can perform a wide
array of tasks out of the box such as
summarization question and answering
classification there are different
modalities for data types such as images
text code and more
for example Google's image Foundation
model Imogen can predict and generate
high quality images from natural
language input these models are
typically trained on vast amounts of
diverse data allowing them to learn
General patterns and representations
that can be applied across various
domains and tasks
and with no or minimal training required
Foundation models can work well out of
the box and can be adapted for targeted
use cases with very little example Data
before now Foundation models were
difficult to access required specialized
machine learning skills and compute
resources to use in production now
developers can access these Foundation
models via apis in the vertex AI model
Garden what is the model Garden
first the model Garden is where you go
to discover both Google and external
models
the garden includes models from Google
Cloud Google research and external
sources for a variety of data formats
including chat and dialogue cogeneration
and completion images and embeddings
let's take a tour of these models
let's start with text which allows you
to perform natural language tasks with
zero and few shot prompted our gallery
of prompts gets you started with tasks
such as summarization entity and
information extraction idea Generation
all in a place for you to experiment
with your own prompts in the studio
let's take a look at an example to get
you started I want my model to tell me
good titles for sample tests
here I have a demo body of text that
describes how humans and robots interact
with each other
then in the last line I asked the model
what the title of this article could be
this works well out of the box but if I
wanted the model to respond with certain
specifications I can feed in examples in
a structured manner in this structure
table I can feed several example pairs
that I've come up with so the model can
follow the nuances that I provide
here we can get a different more
accurate title for the robot sample text
scaling robot learning
next let's talk about dialogue this is
also text based but has been
specifically trained to work in
conversation
dialogue models allow you to have
multi-turn conversations with preserved
contacts
this is useful for an in-browser or
Mobile Assistant to help improve the
customer experience for answering
questions summarization and tune for
your custom domain
now on to code completion and generation
these models can be used to make
supercharged coding assistance
you can give a natural language prompt
to describe a piece of code you'd like
written or use the completion model via
the API and an extension that could take
a partial code snippet as input and then
suggest the output
now let's explore image generation with
these models you can create and edit
images to your specifications we also
have models for working with media such
as classification object detection and
more and built into the product we have
content moderation for responsible AI
safety practices
last but not least embeddings they are
vector representations of data so for
example a text embedding is a numerical
Vector representation of a word or a
phrase
this model allows you to extract
semantic information for unstructured
data you can use this to power
recommendation engines ad targeting
systems complex classification tasks
search and more
Google's curated set of foundation
models available through the model
garden and vertex AI enables you to
quickly find and customize the right
model for your task by using and
customizing the foundation models
available in vertex Ai and the model
Garden you can access a whole new level
of features and functionality
possibilities to help make your apps
more intuitive personalized and
effective at meeting your users needs
learn more about getting started with
vertex Ai and the model Garden by
checking out the links below
foreign